the Joe Rogan experience who which
comics are not to your taste I'm not
saying that you don't like I mean that
are not to your taste that is whose
humor just doesn't kind of well nobody
you mean nothing I could think of
offhand I don't I wouldn't pay attention
one that one things I've gotten really
good at as I've gotten older is not
paying any attention to things I don't
like yeah just just letting it just
slide right out of my brain and onto the
floor I'm not interested it's just I I
spent so much time when I was younger
and stupid or worrying about things I
don't like being upset if things I don't
like well that sucks why do people like
that what the [ __ ] wrong with them and
then realize like what a gigantic waste
of resources that is just a huge waste
of energy yeah that uh I don't care
anymore you know as long as they're not
stealing material as long as they're not
you know doing something terrible to
other comics victimizing as long as
they're not doing that I really don't
care something they're doing well good
luck Zen yeah I tried you mean it's not
I'm just not I mean it's not a hundred
percent it's uh it's constantly a work
of process but my philosophy is rooted
in some sort of a pragmatic
understanding of how my own brain works
yeah like you don't you only have so
much time and you only have so much
energy and if you're wasting your time
on things that you don't like that have
nothing to do with you if people like
something like that's how I feel about
music and and movies and so many things
there's so many things that I just don't
like them at all but some people do I
mean you know some people will that I
think their music is [ __ ]
but they'll have full Staples Center if
people are rocking out well I must be
wrong it's not me it's not them it's
just like everyone's different people
have different tastes some people like
really cheesy rom-coms they like it they
really enjoy it they seek comfort in
this movie where you know it's gonna
work out in the end
it's going to it's not like in the end
the [ __ ] meteor is gonna land on the
building and kill everybody and the
screen is going to splatter with blood
you know their bodies explode you're not
gonna see that in this movie in this
movie everything's gonna work out great
it's this is like by that I've that
feeling about law and order in fact what
am i I have no idea why anyone ever
watch that shows and one of my secret
goals in life is at some point I would
like to be appointed executive producer
of law and order and I want to do ones
that completely subvert yes so we get
you through your all everyone knows
exactly how every one of those shows is
always gonna turn out right and I want
to get to minute 47 and then just go on
some savage you turn that just appalls
at outrageous absolutely and then I'll
be done
I'm quitting and I'm like yeah [ __ ] and
don't tell anybody that Malcolm
Gladwell's taken over no yeah it'd be
totally ins I would push just gently
push Dick Wolf aside and say let me have
this one and we're gonna like completely
and we'll have it you know the the
villain that will actually be one of the
prosecutors that's what we'll do or
something right along those lines in
every episode ends like No Country for
Old Men style or this it's over you're
like what the [ __ ] but there's something
there's a drug in those where they're
comforting and that people know that the
bad guys gonna get caught and the good
guy I don't know this is a random
thought but I don't know any men who
watch them and I've come into the belief
that they are there's something there
actually for women and there are a very
comforting kind of reassuring fantasy
about how the world works that that you
know there the system is so I had
cutting a mite this is an incredibly
complicated theory that I developed once
about these kinds of things
oh so there's we all know what a Western
is yes a Western is where is
conceptually a world in which there is
no law and order and a man shows up and
imposes personally law and order on the
territory the community right so there
is also a eastern what does an Eastern
an Eastern is a place where by contrast
is a story where there are like it's
straight it was four types the eastern
is where there is
Law & Order there's so there are
institutions of justice but they are
have been subverted by people from
within so a nice tune would be the
Serpico is a nice turn it's a crooked
cop who is it's the bad apple who has
you know screwed up that there are lots
of tons and tons of of Hollywood movies
are Easterns the northern is the case
where Law & Order exists and lawn odor
is morally righteous system works law
know that show Law & Order is a northern
it's a functioning apparatus of Justice
which reliably and accurately produces
the right the correct result in
confronting criminality every single day
when it's on TV the southern is where
the the entirely the southern is all
John Grisham novels or Southern's they
are where the entire apparatus is
corrupt and where the reformer is not an
insider but an outsider so in in every
John Grisham novel the same they all
proceed I love John Grisham must be
clear but they all perceived from the
same premise which is the system is
rotten to the core and only this white
knight who comes in from the outside can
save us so in the Western there is no
system in the northern there's a system
as fantastic in in the eastern the
system is reformed from within but in
the southern the system has to be
reformed from without huh that's my
complicated so I feel like anything you
can place all art about law and order
about the criminal world criminal
justice into one of these four
categories and the so the Brits love the
northern so what is you know all of the
the famous British detective stories or
always draw problems Sherlock Holmes
yeah is it northern it's like the system
is like and the you know that there's no
corruption in the police department they
may be bumbling and Charles gotta help
them out but no-one's you know off on
some there's no there's never a case
where there's a rotten cop who's selling
out every is there a modern
version of the Western because westerns
all seem to take place between the time
of like 15 1600 and 1880 there is solely
chai do you read the Jack Reacher novels
my Lu child no but I watched one of the
movies that those are weathers those are
westerns dude you'll never the whole
thing about a West's can you find the
police can you find the police officer
you know I you to find a police officer
in a leech HOD novel they're not nowhere
to be found
Reacher is a retired the hero is a
retired Army investigator he's not even
in the army anymore and it's just
roaming around the country solving
crimes on his own and he'll confront
some massive criminal conspiracy and he
never calls the cops right that's the
whole premise that's so Western you
can't call the cops in the classic
Western because there's no constants we
found right here in Montana on the
border but reach her it's a it's a 21st
century Western so he doesn't call the
cops cuz he doesn't feel like it it's
just like they never appear like and he
just murders everyone out on his own and
then he gets on the train and goes to
the next place
they're amazing I love them so much
[Applause]